this morning a Mafia Boss and Sicily
wanted for 30 years is finally Behind
Bars police captured Mateo Messina
dinaro in a medical clinic he faces
prison time after being convicted for a
series of gruesome murders his arrest is
one more blow in the campaign to take
down a criminal Network that dominated
life in Sicily for decades Chris lipsay
has more
they called him the ghost for 30 years
Italy's most Wanted gangster evaded
capture until now the mass murderer
didn't put up a fight and admitted to
police in Palermo he was Mateo Messina
De Niro it's a name that sends Shivers
in Italy he once allegedly boasted he
could fill a cemetery with his victims
they included the son of a mafia
turncoat the 12 year old was held
hostage for two years then strangled the
body dissolved in acid a bloodlust so
diabolical his nickname was diabolique
with assassinations none more notorious
than those of anti-mafia prosecutors
Giovanni Falcone and Paolo borcelino in
1992 at a monument to those National
Heroes the Prime Minister called the
arrest a great victory for Italy it was
long rumored Messina dinaro had changed
his face with plastic surgery turns out
he didn't even have to change his
glasses thanks to protection in his
native Sicily says criminal law
professor Mauricio bellicosa
De Niro is for sure a leader a chief of
the mafia organization and so it could
take advantage in all these years of a
lot of supports and this is the reason
why it has been so difficult to arrest
in but not everyone supported him locals
cheered his arrest
for me today represents the end the end
of Koza Nostra says Giovanni from
Palermo the old Mass murdering Mafia
that brought down this country is over
he was the last of the top bosses of the
Sicilian Mafia known as the Koza Nostra
so his capture truly marks the end of an
era namely that depicted in The
Godfather movies but while of course
those were fictional the people missing
an arrow killed were very very real Nate
Chris livesay in Rome thank you I mean
this is not like the bada bing Mafia you
see on American TV shows doing Shakedown
a lot of numbers I mean like this is a
there's a black hand period they call it
in Italy where the mafia was at war with
the Italian State it's closer to
terrorism than anything we're familiar
with here in the U.S domestic terrorism
was the ghost
all funneled to uh illegal uh activities
and money and presumably yeah and one
very nice sheepskin code he wore to the
doors people now say that they feel a
lot safer yes for sure they do